Avengers endgame has been on blu-ray for
some time now and the new information
about the movie does not stop piling in
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have learned a ton of information
about Avengers and games since its
release we've gotten plenty of
commentary plenty of deleted scenes and
scenes that never made it into the movie
and today we have another one of those
deleted scenes that never made it into
the movie but it's a scene that
everybody would have died to have seen
in Avengers endgame a scene that would
have been a rematch between the Hulk and
fan oohs so let's talk about this scene
quick reminder if you'd like to win a
ps4 or an Xbox one be sure to subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain I'm picking a
winner at 500,000 subscribers really
soon a rematch between the Hulk and fan
Oh something that fans were dying to see
happen in Avengers in game but sadly we
never got but as it turns out originally
there was a plan for a Hulk versus
Thanos rematch this past weekend was
Disney's fan event d23 that they have
every two years and a lot was revealed
at this year's d23 event including three
new Marvel shows coming to Disney Plus
one of them being she-hulk but one thing
that was revealed that not a lot of
people are talking about is some concept
art for Avengers endgame one piece of
concept art that was revealed at d23
shows Iron Man and rescue or Tony Stark
and pepper kissing in the middle of the
final battle it also shows concept art
of what is being called the iron family
iron man rescue war machine and the iron
spider but then we have concept art for
what we all were dying to see the Hulk
versus Thanos rematch in this concept
art we can see the Hulk punching Thanos
in the face and it seems like he hit him
really really hard this appears to be in
the final battle which makes perfect
sense because that's when 2014 Thanos
showed up and it doesn't appear that the
hoax arm is really damaged at all in
this photo now again this is early
concept art for Avengers in game which
means in the beginning they had a plan
to do a rematch between the Hulk and
Thanos now ultimately they decided to
have the Hulk be the one to snap and
bring everybody back that was dusted by
Thanos a snap and although that is a
critical part to avengers endgame
because the Hulk is probably
the only one who could have survived the
snap a lot of people were pretty
underwhelmed with the Hulk story arc and
Avengers in game and pretty disappointed
that we didn't see much action from him
and sadly this concept art reveals that
there actually was going to be a decent
amount of action from the Hulk if he was
going to fight Thanos so what did you
think
did you like and were you satisfied with
the Hulk story arc and Avengers endgame
him being the one to snap and bring
everybody back or would you have liked
to see the Hulk versus Thanos rematch
let me know in the comments down below
also comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
don't forget to follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof